Next up. Welcome Avel. We have Avel
Gwenen carlo with embedded normativity.
So thanks Avel to you.
Hello. Can you hear me? Yep.
And can you see the slides? I only
see the top left of the slide.
You only see the top just yeah.
Try again. Thank you.
Okay, about now? Yep. Looks great.
Thank you. Okay, good.
So I am Avelina Carlo. I'm interested in
multiscale collective organization.
This is why I came to active in France
to begin with. And the core question
I've been asking is basically when we
look at human organization, there is
creative evolution, there is a change
through time of the specific patterns
that are enacted. And this is very hard
to account for. And I have been trying
to pin down more and more specifically
what exactly is going on and how to
model it. So this specific work is a
work I wrote in the context of my PhD.
Of course, which is funded by the Escape
Project, a project in cognitive
archaeology that's interested in how
the archaeological landscape shape
cognition and vice versa. The title of
it is automated. No activity. An active
inference of agency. An active inference
account of agency being flesh because
you will see very quickly why. So first
we will go through the existing work on
anchor cognition in the context of
active inference. Then we'll try to
expose the concept of embedded Motivity,
which we introduce here and what it
means. And then we'll look at the more
semiotic question around the
externalization and utilization of
normativity in cultural landscapes.
So first encouraged cognition in active
in France. So we know active inference.
I will go quickly over it. I still need
to do it because there are lookers that
are not familiar. So active inference
say that agents continuously predict
the specific queues sensory cues they
will see, and they predict the action or
policy they will not take. And they
basically enact an ongoing stream of
expectation that they reconstruct given
upcoming signal. So this is best Akotin
four in this schema which shows
the agent as the nickel system, which
engage through environment, through
action and cessations. And all of these
specific domains, they minimize
a specific function that is called free
energy and whose minimization basically
means there is a prerogative process
going on. And a core
property of active inference is that it
dissolves agency as we typically
understand it. We don't have agents that
have like an internal monologue that
drives them to take decision. We have a
conscious anticipation of what's going
on. And whatever an agent anticipates
itself to do, it will do. And so this
goes for computationally satisfying but
very deflationary notion of what is
going on with agency. So the
question then comes what is the relation
between an agent and the cognitive
landscape in which it evolves? I will
present very rapidly again the framework
of Skill and a pioneered by Brunborg,
Kierstein and Reidfield,
and which says that Skill agents, which
we understand as agents that understand
what is going on around them, they will
basically experience the world as a
landscape of affordances, which is
opportunities for actions and their
cognition pretty much reduces to the
experience of this landscape and
adaptive engagement with it, which
basically maximize the grip the agent
has on the system and essentially
for reasons we will not go over because
it's math the very existence experience
of this landscape. It is equivalent to
the existence of constraints over
attention. The attention that the agent
gives to thing which translates
the embodied expectation that are two
times embodied bad the embodied
expectation that the agent enacts.
And so this becomes very interesting
when we cross it with the existence of
enculturation in humans because the
basic experience we have of affordances,
of what we can do it is shaped
culturally, it is shaped by interaction
wherein we learn with other humans about
what we do, what we can do and what we
can do. And this means that the basic
human experience, it's thoroughly
encultured. It's embedded in what
Ramshed called landscape of cultural
fondencies and it is embedded in
cultural and material regimes
of attention so ways to pay attention to
things. And this is a figure that comes,
I believe, from this year on thinking
throughout the minds where it shows
basically how the action installation
cycle. When we have several agents,
they build a common environment that has
epistemic cues on how the world is like
and we are enculturated to pay attention
to things in a certain manner that makes
it so. We perceive and enact this
landscape and so the uncultured
constraint over the flow of attention
because of what we saw just before the
deflationary account of agency. It means
that the very expensive landscape,
cultural landscape that is collectively
enacted, it effectively integrates
intentionality, it effectively
integrates normativity in a way that
clashes strongly with classical account
of both. So,
given this state of the art,
let us look at what I mean specifically
by embedded normativity. So embedded
Motivity is a kind of normativity, I
think you have got it. So normativity
it means basically the criterions by
which we judge things to be good and bad
in the context of biological system they
will look for specific, I don't know,
chemical concentration and they will
avoid other this is the phenomenon of
chemotaxis, this is pretty basic and
this is a form of normativity. But for
humans we will typically think of laws,
cultural norms, culturally shared
way to judge behavior and again,
at least in the context of law and
choice theory we typically think there
is an agent, he has access to
information and will think what should I
do? And he will judge rationally about
what is good and what is bad based on a
collection of values which are internal
to the agent. This is not how it works.
What I call embodied Motivity is by
contrast regimes of normal activity
where it is the norms and value that
guide the agent's behavior. It is
embedded in the material and cultural
environment. So basically the agent
projects a specific set of norms and
value in the very experienced fitness
environment and it will perceive
the locus of normativity as the
environment and not as a form of
internal judgment.
Let us look at what can exactly how
embedded Motivity work. It will be more
concrete. So first we can materially
constrain people to do things. So for
example, there are roads, you can go off
roads but it's harder and you can't
really do that if you are a chariot. So
when you have a specific pattern of
roads which is constructed by cities you
are pretty much constrained to follow
the roads materially and for this we
will talk of structural embedding and
there is another regimes of
mezzanomativity where we build on
environments that will basically cue you
suggest you into adopting specific norms
and specific values. For example,
Escape thinks that vertical patterns in
archaeological culture they are somehow
embedded within what we'd call vertical
norms. So hierarchy and certification in
social relationship and for this
specific form of embedding we can talk
of semantic embedding. What must be
very clear is that we don't have
structural embedding on one side and
semantic embedding there are basically
two mechanism, complementary mechanism
in which embedded normativity occurs.
If we look at city so this is impression
of sumerian culture city states we
have matter organization that prompts
specific kind of behavior. So for
example, we have a bridge and this
bridge allow you constrain you to go
through the river in a specific way if
you are on foot. But these material
constraints it is perceivable. So by
seeing the bridge you will also see that
you can navigate the world in this
specific way. So you don't have a
sparration between semantic and
structural embedding. We just have two
ways in which constraints of our
behavior that are embedded in the
environment work,
and something that is core to the
account of embedded non activity is,
again, that it is not internal. But we
need to go into more detail about what
we mean by not being internal, because,
of course, we're talking about agency
agents constrain what agents do. It's
not outside what it is is
embedded. In Motivity is a regime of the
multivity where the norms and value,
they stem from the experience of
Fordance. For example, if I see fire I
will not think about hey, could I
put my hand in it and get my hand burn?
I think it would be painful. I won't do
that. If I even think about putting my
hand in the fire I will immediately feel
bad. The normativity it's embedded in my
experience of the world. I feel like the
fire or more specifically the
possibility of putting my hand in the
fire is intrinsically bad. I do not feel
there is a possibility that is neutral
and then I judge to be bad.
But of course this
judgment does not occur outside even if
I feel like it's about my affordances.
It emerges from the engagement I have
with the material and cultural niche in
which I find myself. And if we
want to untangle what this
means precisely we will have to go into
more detail into what I call the
externalization internalization of many
normativity. So let us look at something
very simple how normativity work for
embodied agents. So embodied agents,
they do things hopefully in a
niche that is material and this niche
will be marked by the activity of my
agent. And these marks, they can then
act as constraints either through
structural or cementing embedding in the
agent's firmament because they basically
signify that in the past I wanted to do
that. Maybe doing that is good. For
example, we have centuries with I don't
know if centuries English word but web
path if animals that have legs this is
actually important walk on a specific
path, they will compact the earth and it
will become improper to grow anything,
even grass. And you will have paths that
will emerge that are pretty neat, it's
pretty visible and that tell you hey,
not only this earth is compact and allow
you to walk on it without effort but
also this has been widely judged to
be a good outline
for navigation in this specific
environment. So the very experience of a
path basically invites you you
perceive the affordance of walking
through the path and this is something
that again can result from your own
activity that can be written into
development by your own activity.
And so this begs the question of how
okay, there exists embedded nomativity
but how do we embed nomativity? What is
the activity of embedding mativity like?
And the word I will use for that is
externalization. We perceive the world
because we externalize specific causes
of sensation into an imagined objective
external world. So when we see the path,
we see a path. We do not see compact
earth that we then compute to mean
that other things have worked on it. We
just see hey, there is a path. And this
is because we have externalized a
specific cognitive kind which is the
path. And this is argument that
several people made here lene Steiner,
which if I remember well, worked on the
production of devices that help blind
people see things through,
I believe an array of repetitive device
on their shoulder. So the core
argument they make is that if you give
people that they will start seeing
things, they will start perceiving
things as being before them rather than
having vibration on the shoulder and
then thinking about what does it mean.
And so the basic argument is that
perception is just picture
of what cause we infer, what is the
structure we infer of our environment
given the existence of a specific
coupling device that relates action to
sensation and vice versa. And this
critically relies on the internalization
of specific. We could say a lot of
things that I will say priors specific,
priors knowledge and perception. So me
seeing the path as a path relies on me
having the prior knowledge that there is
such a thing as paths and I should be
expecting to see them around. And so you
have duality of externalization and
internalization in the production of
embedded mativity. I can only see norms
out there if I've internalized
integrated a specific apparatus of
perception that entails that there are
indeed those specific norms that are
embedded in those specific affordances.
And so this produce a more general
question of semantics, particularly of
information theory. How do reading and
writing and reading maturity works?
So when I extend lies I treat
the world as having specific natural
categories that I pretty much imagine
and I can use them because I imagine
them as an extended memory that allow me
to read and write normative cues. This
can be letters, pure signs.
But as far as I'm concerned here, all
signs are at least implicitly normative.
There about how you should interpret the
sign. And this means that
we can experience specific landscape of
forensics and we
can write things out there. We can write
normative cues, bio behavior that will
then constrain further behavior. But
nothing tells us that we
can communicate through this. The
communication, it works because of the
internalization of prayers. If a given
community of agents have internalized a
specific set of prayers that is, a set
of prayers that enable externalization
of numerative cues, then only it can use
the environment as a way to write
and read. Normative queues as embedded
normativity thing. And this
communication, it can be read in terms
of information theory. Of course it can
be read in terms of semantics. But what
is critical to analyze that the process
of internalization there is no
trust system there is no private key
that allow you to be sure that the way
you internalize norms is very
specifically the way in which the
Emily Mativity was encouraged to begin
with. There is a loss, or there is
ambiguity, or there is I'd rather say it
like this an active demarch of
reconstruction, of given prayers by the
agent. And so this gap between
the intent of other communicants and my
intent, my understanding of what they
meant by their active engagement with
the world, it builds a tiny gap in
information that is somehow enough to
drive the open ended evolution of
cultural landscape. And this is
something that I do not think is
embedded in active in France and I think
is of major interest to research, to the
research at least in the evolution of
open end evolution of cultural
landscape. So to sum up things,
I just presented a paper that is called
anomaly Motivity and that speaks
unsurprisingly of embedded normativity.
First major point is that if active
inference is correct, then our
notion of agency is dissolved
essentially in the notion that we can
perceive and enact cognitive landscape.
Umvelt, if you want. And given
that this is the case, we will
experience the norms and value that
guide our behavior as a property of the
cognitive landscape. We experience the
affordance that we can perceive and
this specific regime of normativity I
call embedded normativity. And the third
thing is that you have a critical thing
going on. You have a semiotically
constraining thing going on in the
externalization and internalization of
regimes of embedded mativity because
those two things they respectively
enable embedded Motivity to exist, to
have a causal power and they enable also
the open ended evolution of the norms
that are embedded in a given landscape
in a given material landscape and
therefore the open end evolution of the
asseted, cultural or committee
landscape. So thank you. I will
enroll my references slides in case
someone really needs to know what the
reference is and is ready to move around
the video for this. And do you have
questions? Awesome. Thank you.
Avel, while people are typing any
questions, could you maybe just give a
little introduction to the active
inference for the Social Sciences
course? Like, what brought you to want
to facilitate this effort and where are
we at and where do you want it to go?
What do you want it to be for?
Oh, mute and then continue.
Good point. Thank you. The Active
Inference Institute organizes and kerose
Research organize a course on active
inference in the social science that is
based essentially in explaining the
basic demarch, the basic hypothesis and
the consequences of the cultural
landscape formalism that I hinted at
slightly in this presentation.
The goal of the course is to give basic
ontology that is an interface between
complexity science, let us say physics,
written large cognitive science and
social science to afford
interdisciplinary collaboration in
the social science and in the study of
the evolution of human societies. And I
think it is cool, but I'm biased because
I've missed it. So maybe you should ask
Daniel, which is absolutely unbiased,
whether the course is cool. I've been
enjoying it a lot. We just finished last
week with my section on collective
behavior. First we had the introduction
lecture from you, then Ben White on the
basics of being an active agent. And we
have Lorena and Mao's sections upcoming,
as well as your more dedicated session.
Yeah, it's been a really fun experience
and it's going to provide a really
useful missing piece
in the ecosystem, I guess. Just one
question. How do we take some of these
topics you're bringing in about the
embedded normativities and think about
them digitally? Like, are we talking
about conceptual embeddedness
in information environments and or are
we talking about the ergonomics of
sitting at our desk? Or how do we bring
that kind of pleasure path stigma g
on the ground into the digital are we
talking about something that's embodied
and embedded in the information space
or are we still talking about bodies?
So if we talk about humans, we talk
about bodies with the brain that do
things in a mature environment. But your
question is I'm not sure understood is
how can we bring this specific concept
in the study of digital phenomena? I
cannot. Twitter internet. Is that
it? Yeah. Okay, so you have basically
the whole study on the affordances,
the discipline of design has
incorporated a while ago the national
affordance in its structure. And most of
the study in the digital design centers
are on what platforms afford or do not
afford. And you have richer
stance when you take into account not
what you can do with a specific
interface, but what the specific
interface invites you to do. Given a set
of cultural written large,
it can be self learning,
but given a set of power that you share
with the platform in a
way that is formal but indirect
yes. I would look at it in terms of user
interface design. I think this concept
specifically is useful for
interface design. Then you
have implicitly the question of the flow
that platforms such as, I don't know,
twitter. Facebook how specific structure
environments bring specific collective
dynamics that may be a bit richer.
Not richer specifically, but that may go
in. A direction that the user face
question do not go into and that can
still be modeled in terms of constraints
and therefore in terms of embedded
normativity. Is that on point?
We'll go to your question.
Yeah, that's interesting about what the
interface does and then what it invites.
It might invite things. In order
for that invitation to be fulfilled, it
has to actually provide that
possibility. But it might invite things
that aren't relationally possible. Like
there might be a wall which invites
climbing to a given observer, yet they
cannot climb it. And then on the other
side is a capacity
that isn't invited and that is
the adjacent possible of tool use where
something that was being used for this
purpose, it's like all of a sudden it
just fell out of someone's hand. They
grasped it a different way, it invited a
different engagement. And then that can
become re entrenched and that points to
that sequential making and breaking of
new spaces that your work has featured
over the last few years. Yes, exactly.
This work has been developed while
thinking about tool use, while thinking
about cognitive archaeology, while
thinking about the experience of cities,
the way urbanism prompts specific
behavior. But if I can
get back on the Internet thing, I'd like
to make it more specific. So the
interface design, as far as I know is
focused on interface.
That is not surprising, but in doing
so it is focused on specific fordance
and what you can do. You have another
layer in ecological psychology, which is
the layer of solicitation. So, for
example, Twitter does something very
specific, which is when you log in,
it shows you the number of notifications
you have, then it removes it and you
have to wait to know which were those
notification. And you have to wait not 1
second, not 1 minute, but a random
amount of time. So this is what they
call dark patterns. They are patterns in
design that are explicitly designed to
create addiction. So this is a layer you
can't afford in affordance, because from
an affordance perspective there is just
a moment you can access the information
and then a moment you can't, and then
the moment you can again, there is
nothing going on. If you don't look at
intrinsic motivation and the way
specific structure, environment is
perceived, the semantics, maybe the
meaning that given landscape has for an
agent. And even if you look at this,
you are still looking at the platform in
a way that is embedded from the specific
patterns, that specific patterns
of things that people do on the
platform. If you have Twitter without
the aggressive QRTs and the way to
aggressively signal that you are in
whatever it is, is going on, you don't
have Twitter much, you have Mastodon
maybe that has very similar affordances
and very dissimilar solicitation.
So this is why you have to take
multiscale account of things. And when
you take multiscale account of things
you have to look at the semiotics
basically behavior, how specific
coordination occur at specific scales
around specific communication, specific
message passing. And once you look
at how specific message become
meaningful to specific agent,
you have a problem basically because
this is subjective, this is constructed
through the activity of the agent and
whatever is the range of time you are
looking at, you will have the
construction of new possibilities of
adjustment possibles as you put it. And
and yeah, this is the
big question that I think we are missing
at the moment in active inference.
Awesome. Well, thank you for this
presentation. Thanks for the social
sciences work and we're all looking
forward to seeing how the projects play
out. Thank you. Goodbye. Farewell AVO.